the Joe Rogan experience there's
different ways to make polymers so that
they can recycle it they just took the
cheapest way possible because they know
it's not coming back
right so you have to put it either you
have to put a tax on virgin plastic to
make it valuable for people to be able
to recycle it otherwise great solution
is hemp plastic it's biodegradable and
comes from this plant meaning you can
make hemp plastic and we can grow it and
it's an easy crop that's scalable yes
hemp is so weird it doesn't even seem
like it should be real I mean it really
doesn't it's it's an it's an insane
plant I mean you can make hempcrete out
of it which is far better than any
building material we currently use it's
far more resistant to flame there's
there's just so many positive benefits
of it in terms of insulation the
insulation factors better than wood or
plywood it's really lightweight but
incredibly strong if you were like
grabbed a thick hemp stock if you ever
held onto one no it doesn't seem real
it's hard like this oak but yet it's
light like balsa wood it's so strange it
feels like it comes from another planet
Wow hemp is an extraordinary planet it's
a most extraordinary plant we have first
of all it has all the essential amino
acids I love hemp protein it's one of my
favorite proteins for we salad it on it
we sell hemp protein it's one of the
very best proteins in terms of being
able to mix it and like a protein shake
and on the go your body digests it super
easily and it's like filled with amino
acids it's very easy for your body
digestive process you can make oil out
of it that they used to use for [ __ ]
for heating lamps you can cook your food
in it it I mean there's so many
different things you could do with hemp
you can make clothing you can make far
more durable cloth far more durable the
paper is far superior in fact the whole
reason why William Randolph Hearst
demonize marihuana in the first place
was to protect his business because he
had paper mills and he was trying to
protect it from hemp because on the
cover of popular science magazine they
had come out with a decor Decatur decor
Decatur was a way in the 1930s they
devised two effective
process hemp fiber because for years
they used to use slaves to process hemp
then when they figured out the cotton
Jen cotton became easier to use and then
slavery became outlawed and so people
who shied away from hemp well they came
up with this decor Decatur in the 1930s
it was on the cover of popular science
magazine hemp the new billion-dollar
crop well William Randolph Hearst didn't
just own hourss publications and
newspapers he also are owned these huge
forests that they were making paper with
so he along with Harry Anslinger and
using his newspapers demonized marijuana
to stop the commodity of hemp yes no
idea he funded all those [ __ ] crazy
marijuana movies reefer madness all that
[ __ ] that was all him they came up with
these stories that these Mexicans and
black men were taking this new drug
called marijuana marijuana wasn't even a
term for cannabis marijuana was a term
for a wild tobacco so they came up with
his new name they called it this drug
everybody freaked out because they
didn't have the internet back then no
one had access to real information other
than Hearst Newspapers Hearst
publications so he's just [ __ ] out
now lied and made up these crazy stories
and funded these documentaries and then
marijuana became illegal and still is to
this day and you still have knuckleheads
like Joe Biden literally yesterday
saying that he thinks marijuana is a
gateway drug but we're still in this and
but forget about marijuana imagine if it
wasn't psychoactive at all the idea that
hemp should be illegal until really
recently in this country is a [ __ ]
travesty it's horrific its food its
clothes it's paper it doesn't even make
sense that it could be so many things
it's literally like one of the most
positive plants of the Earth's ever
known okay vote for it man
dude you should do a nice documentary on
that I think you got to Joe Biden easy
ah Joe [ __ ] you too late there's a lot
to talk on here where I stand a one hour
ago I put my [ __ ] Instagram post out
this morning Scott they did this one
I basically had a well worded thing
saying that anyone who thinks that
marijuana should be legal is basically
saying you should be locked in a cage
for experimenting with your
consciousness and the freedom to - to do
whatever you want with your body that is
especially with marijuana that's not
poisonous no one's died of it everyone
ever and they history the human race is
never a single overdose for marijuana
and this knuckleheads saying that it's a
gateway drug no pain is a gateway drug
Strama is a gateway drug abuse is a
gateway to drugs it's not marijuana
marijuana is just a time-honored
psychedelic substance that people have
been enjoying for thousands and
thousands of years run for Congress [ __ ]
that I'm not running for anything I'm
not even running for my neighborhood
whatever the hell it is I just saw a
poster over there did he run for mayor
is that a joke what post don't know I
thought that supposed to oh it's a
hundred percent a joke look I'm not ever
running for anything ever well it was
fit was right next to Hunter Thompson
for mayor and I thought well maybe maybe
there was some truth to it no it's
Hunter Thompson for sheriff but there's
nothing Jeremy I don't think notice
Hunter Thompson That's not me look I'm
not running for anything ever I have
three jobs and three kids I'm busy and I
have a lot of hobbies too many hobbies
I'm trying to chip away at hobbies but
if I can get Joe Biden to shut the [ __ ]
up I'm very happy crazy [ __ ] there's
so many people that smoke pot in this
country he's so crazy for him to come
out against that is so goddamn dumb how
do you smoke pot on the show and still
hold a conversation though I'm a STONER
I know how to do it I don't be doing it
forever look one of the things that I
said in my Instagram post today
marijuana is not for everybody and I
think it should be used carefully
because look I've said a lot of dumb
[ __ ] when I've been high I've thought a
lot of dumb [ __ ] I've been paranoid it's
not for everybody I think it should be
treated cautiously but there's a lot of
benefits to it I really firmly believe
that it's made me a more sensitive
person it's made me more interested in
community it's made me more aware of how
important it is that we're all connected
and that we all converse with each other
in a calm
way it's made me feel better about about
a happy communication with people it's
made me more affectionate it's made me
more compassionate more kind as it makes
me more aware you know that the feeling
of paranoia one of the things that that
paranoia is is just an overall expanding
of your awareness of your vulnerability
[Applause]